right under 37 percent he can keep you
honest out there
cj will once again take valentine's to
the rim and has success
a second time things aren't going well
could always use valencianas
cj mccollum with the finishes we go to
rob
merkich with the screen mccullum with
the straightaway three puts it in
and cj mccollum with 13.
we'll see here around the screen we
talked about the biggs will have to be
involved somewhat with mccullum and
lillard
and josh jackson lillard and mccullum
with nurkic anthony and hezonja
carmelo anthony just a slight pause good
hands from mello
cj gets the loose ball dame on the wing
looking for his first three
count it so dame splashes the three
after the land and a five point flurry
facing up into the jump shot good kick
out from cj
john morant came to the paint he
collapsed him so he knows you got to go
close out on my man got to take him off
that line
should he had a two for 18 performance
against the milwaukee bucks in the first
game of the bubble he also didn't shoot
well in the scrimmage as
lillard sets up beautifully
dame into the paint kicks back out to
lazonia the zonia loses that one dame
picks it up
tough baseline jumper gets that one to
splash
number 44. he gets to the paint ball
gets dislodged but
dame is there to pick up ninth for 13 24
total points between the two
walker hasn't missed yet carmelo anthony
spotting up for three
that's a beautiful pass by mccullum and
just sort of mucks the lane up to
prevent the shot blocker
from coming over that time he got called
for an offensive foul
nice back door and a beautiful feed as
damian lillard
gets his second field goal in this third
quarter
collins back in the game sat most of the
first half with three fouls
mellow gets the finish more great blazer
ball movement nice job from cj to curl
about a 30-footer as good as it gets
taking contact shooting three-pointers
at the line running over screening rolls
once that guy is in pursuit he stops
and get it done both ways tend to shoot
white side handles with ties defending
cj wants to join the party and cj
mccollum
buries the three and the blazers come
back from 21 down
smart gets on the high side cj sees it
dame says cj you go ahead and take it
tatum has been the hot hand for the
celtics working down low he crumbles
loose ball collins gets on the floor
and the blazers regroup in a tie ball
game cj his three from outside
count it one two three here baby for
sure though that he slid it but he got
on the floor got the ball to damon watch
jaylen brown he was so close dame got
rid of that ball 3j on the other side oh
it's good cj
mccollum
lillard get it in early sealing the area
and it's nurkic
rocking the rim
collins and then lillard ahead as nurkic
goes
rim runs on the break has shot 32
percent from the field
30 from three-point territory
mccallum step back beautiful
cj mccollum better job there by the
blazers making russell westbrook extend
on the catch out of hardin's trap
oh a rack attack for nurkic
great pass by lillard and a great finish
by nurkic he's got great hands
keeps the ball up gives nobody a chance
westbrook loses it coughed it up here's
lillard
all the way bucket and the foul
take a page out of james harden's book
he's struggling in the half court
to get some opportunities in transition
to get himself going jeremy grant he was
always a problem for the blazers when he
played with okc
as dame unloads the walk up three tory
craig says my bad
should have had a hand up with the
turnover but you love damon the early
start so far he just walked torry craig
into that three tory craig thinking dame
is getting ready to utilize the screens
i was happy to retire early and get away
from sports
because it is not fun cj's three is off
blazers control
dame will get a second at him so damien
lillard eight points
two for two from beyond the arc in this
first quarter we'll try the land
denied by collins back come the blazers
great job
by zach to stay in front oh here he goes
dame from kissimmee florida nails that
one so
dame three for three from beyond the arc
four from beyond the arc doesn't matter
how far
in the charge it was a defensive
entanglement and those things happen
sometimes
especially in the month of august
lillard pipes another three so
damien lillard five for six from the on
the
blazers with collins nurkic cj dame and
gary trent
jr collins two-point jump shot for him
is good that's nice offense two screens
up high
collins up top dame trying to free
himself up from craig we know
craig he's getting physical defender
against dame cj finds an error
over mount ball gets the dunk the harm
the highlight rip city you can find that
poster here in a few weeks
[Applause]
[Applause]
gabriel in disbelief damn nearly at
midcourt
once the mellow screen again dame splits
a pair of defenders pull up three at the
buzzer
damian lillard ladies and gentlemen 18
points
make it 20 now turnovers it denver
scoring off of the blazers turnovers and
and the blazers
they don't turn the ball over a lot oh
and one
so down has a chance to get four the
hard way as craig
trail a nudge one more look how quick he
stops
the ball was in his left hand he just
turned it to that right hand
and then pulled up instantly knowing
that craig was on his body
stays under control he gets to his spots
and he just rises up over the top of
people
lillard rising up but he misses from the
outside oh that is
really deep damien lillard makes it look
so easy on his acceleration
look how deep this is i mean those used
to be
considered bad shots in the nba now we
are finally
getting the chance to see all that merc
hands off to cj cj
flips it outside nerc will take a rhythm
bounce and yousef
nurkish joining the three-point party
eric from outside
you are in a lot of trouble nba if this
guy gets
really comfortable shooting this shot
because he's already half
of the best pick-and-roll in basketball
when he's a roll man
now if he gets to have the chance to say
well this time i want to pop
also been just some instances of guys
making jump shots over the top gary
trent jr unconscious
whoever stiffens up defensively here
first
there's a team that can take control of
this game the column
from really deep to protect the paint on
pick and roll
so they're not up to contest the three
the same as zubach does it this
feed mccullum slick pass for nurkic
and a foul call
nurkic creates this first by tipping the
ball out and getting the offensive
rebound
mccullum rewards him with the dish
feeds your big guy puts it in the bucket
not mad at you
but right now right now there is no
point guard playing better than damien
lillard
but you know you want to bring in all
this playoff series
here's lillard breaking free
good fine to mccullum step back three
count it
cj mccullum in terms of the number of
step back threes people hit
he creates about six feet on that step
post pass from joelle to tobias he sees
so many come his way he knows what the
good ones look like here he is again yep
once again
lillard all the way to the cup for a
second bucket
he's not you know starting all these
problems
but he will respond if you take it to
his doorstep he will respond
responding with an assist to win
this was the basket from winning dame
drives horford
provides the early help of anybody in
the league
they find certain players to go at and
they get you in foul trouble
oh and dame we're gonna just break that
down for you here real quick
two points because he's the closest
person to the
to the basket thank you tobias harris
jumper melo sneers it
six minutes left damian lillard really
aggressive early on and damien lillard
and one but he goes right back to it in
transition
defense isn't completely set al horford
not there in time to provide the help
so dame can see visually the gap attacks
it you got to take that away from him
it's a matchup and richardson wasn't
having it dame races to the cup
and one more gold at the cup going back
to what he started the game with
just attacking head down one man to beat
and it's a big man so he knows he has
the foot speed
to beat him to the rim like they do all
the time on the jump shout out to rachel
nichols and crew with shots like that
good pass
back door
[Applause]
energy but he will dunk when the time
calls for when he needs to route his
team up a little bit
the margin right now for the sixers
lillard thinking about it mccollum gives
it up anthony back into the game and he
laces a three
[Music]
richardson really up in the grill of
damian lillard here eight seconds
dame able to force the foul the bucket
and
damien lillard lies in how you're being
played richardson
not relenting at all all up in
and them just cuts off his path
knows richardson is going to run back
into the play
takes the numbers don't show it
he's going to be an outstanding
three-point shooter i think so and
that's probably what scares the heck out
of
all of the nba coaches showing you the
lateral ability to stay in front
[Music]
dame gets porzingis once again and hits
the turbo button man that's a lot of
separation on that drive
damien exploding along this baseline
[Music]
coming off a two or 14 shooting
performance the other night
here the shot clock at seven works on
jared allen
got it to go 2-0 create off the bounce
lillard has it coming off 61 charges
inside and there's a nice
feed and nurkic will finish it off what
a fine by karis levert it looked like a
mirror for seeing lillard to nurkic
mccullum the quick breakdown in the easy
bucket
when embiid was just moving him like a
ragdoll left and right but he's put on
weight good point and it has not stopped
his
ability to run the floor lever tried to
shove that ball in here they come now
with mccollum off delivered look at the
speed look at the guy
for the nets jordan i don't know if they
can hang in there
throughout an entire game cj with the
deflection dave comes down the other way
and dame floats it up
alive blazers got the steal here
get it to the middle of the floor cj
goes to the left that's always a good
option
point here in this first half for the
nets try it inside mccullum
picked up and then stolen allen couldn't
get it
nurkish got it and it's up in it
he was six of nine oh my look at this
shot by the way that was from the nba
logo oh my goodness what a
shock you've got to be kidding me people
one dribble over half court
dead center that was taken from
corvallis wow what a
shot four-point game the wahwoo cabaret
gets the loose ball
gets it off to levert hounded oh what a
defensive play by
lillard he stole the ball what a play by
lillard
the blazers of star started over three
from the field all their points have
been from the free-throw line
lillard stepped back three that's good
that's a tough
sense change the ability to dictate your
own pace
and create your own shot dolla
[Applause]
the column goes back door collins is
gonna try that corner three again this
time it goes down
prior to the lead being suspended
but the extra time really helped him
where
once he came back he was ready to play
mccollum's
sweet jumper there
[Applause]
lillard gets a good look that's a three
second three-pointer of the game for
damien littler to tie the game
extremely talented rookies
[Music]
give and go lullard throws it down over
valenciunis wow
i talk about terry stotts as a defensive
minded coach he was that
as rick carlisle's assistant as damian
lillard buries a three
you see a timeout oh he's a defensive
coach well if you can't coach offense
you should just be an assistant coach
and help on the defensive side
that's been very difficult for the
lakers they were three and five
since the restart of course most of
those games didn't mean a thing
around the pit comes lillard it's
nothing but net
for damian lillard portland may have to
switch up and go back to that zone a
little bit
not let the offense of the lakers know
it's coming
mcculloch has been quiet but knocks that
one down needed that cj mccullum
just a second made field goal pick and
roll and cj right here getting a little
bit of a
space against the taller kuzma step back
bang
blazers the 8c taking on the number one
seeded los angeles lakers dame
blazers cj rhythm dribble he strikes
first in the second half
ball on the baseline one point six
seconds collapses everybody
and winyan wisely makes the extras harry
trent jr now
lost the handle and now gotta go nine
seconds on the shot clock damian lillard
looking for someone
finds mccullum pow bury's a three cj
mccullum
the floor gets poked away saves it to
gabriel
dame one second left to shoot for free
damian
lillard buries the three and the blazers
pull within one possession
they've led most of this game at one
point had a 16 point lead
in the second quarter early mccullum
can't shake caruso fires it anyway in
traffic he buries a three
tough shot and it's because the lakers
can't have that much spacing you know
why they don't have many three-point
shooters
like that like that damien
lillard one up on the lakers
if you don't do that one dribble don't
foul get out the way white side
and let dave have his time nurkic
deflects it
[Applause]
well the lakers bigs like to contest and
then
leak out as lillard finishes
and three-point play opportunity back in
deflecting that
which led to this euro step
three-point play by lillard
so mcgee picking up 33 free throw
attempts
in game one they've only taken nine free
throws here tonight
cj mccollum and frank vogel calls the
timeout
and anthony davis one for five from the
line to start the game
and he's an 85 percent free-throw
shooter this season
cj mccollum sweeps move inside on the
scoop layup
carmelo anthony guarding lebron james
ball poked away
great play by anthony with active hands
lillard knocks that one down damien
lillard
two for two to start and it leads to
this damian lillard
pull up three
column and magee isolated shoots over
the seven footer and knocks it down cj
mcconnell his second field goal tough
one over the big hands
of javale mcgee it's your own shot i
don't need damon lillard on the floor to
make a play for me
get me the basketball get out of my way
and allow me to dance
but i'm saying how do you how do you
find it if i want to before my walk
tomorrow
do i go to a certain thing pandora
i don't know what that is but you make a
great point about kuzma's cut good job
moving without the basketball we see so
many guys today falling in love
with that three-point line littler gets
to the rim lay-up shots good
at one day and lillard 13 points
already here
a little confusion where the big man is
supposed to be
caruso's forcing him to his right davis
is up with the screener so he's late
so it's a shot you have to be willing to
give up to him
again he only had 10 total points the
entire game too
cj mccollum once again his third
three-pointer
last two minutes
lillard simons they swing it mccollum
nice ball fake corner three
got it at the buzzer siege the corner
gets into the thick the pass turns down
a shot by trent for the better shot
mccullum
good old-fashioned game of pool prior to
the shutdown had wins over milwaukee had
wins
over the clippers as well there's a big
hit for
the blazers 21 assists for the lakers on
34
made baskets that's gonna be a foul on a
three ball
bottom hash mark and find that little
space in here
the very first play when mellow thought
he was fouled on
a play and didn't get the call and we've
seen that frustration manifest all night
through their play
first basket of the game for dion
waiters mccullum
inside scores it and that's going to
take us to the end of the third quarter
here
[Applause]
davis completes the three-point play
lakers take their first lead to this one
cj
beautiful fake on caldwell pope and over
the top and down the chute
lamar on the catch caldwell pope forcing
cj toward the baseline
he'll gladly accept that was he moving
you got to be set right there he's
trying to clear the way for
lebron and cj with a quick strike back
to even this thing up grasps that
basketball
and cj getting off to a great start
cj mccollum at the controls here tonight
shakes kcp
and barry's a three cj mccullum